قالت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه ان سفاره
الاتحاد الاوروبي في اسرائيل قد الغت حفلا
بمناسبه يوم اوروبا وارد بن جزير على
القرار الاوروبي بالقول ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يدعي تمثيل الديمقراطيه
يتعامل بسياسه تكميم الافواع على نحو غير
دبلوماسيه من جانبه قال زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ان الحكومه الحاليه ادخلت
اسرائيل في ازمه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي فقط
من اجل السماح لبنجفير باحراجنا امام
العالم حسب قوله
انضم الينا الان من القدس مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرامه الياس اهلا بك موقف اذا يسجله
الاتحاد الاوروبي في اسرائيل اليوم ماذا
عن خلفياته وابعاده
بالفعل سفيان بالامكان القول بان الاتحاد
الاوروبي قال اليوم بما لا يتركوا مكانا
للشك او التاويل بان وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي التمار بن فيرو هو شخصيه غير
مرغوب فيها في الاتحاد الاوروبي والاتحاد
الاوروبي في قراره الغاء هذا الحفل الرسمي
السنوي هو كان يرد على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالقول بانه لن يقبل بان يكون
بنك فير مندوبا عن الحكومه في هذا الحفل
لانه لا يتماشى ولا يتوافق مع مواقف ورؤى
وقيم الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذه القيم التي
يمثلها الاتحاد الاوروبي مصدر رفيع
المستوى في الخارجيه الاسرائيليه كما نقلت
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه قال بان هذا
الموقف من جانب الاتحاد الاوروبي يشكل
صفعه مدويه للحكومه الاسرائيليه الاتحاد
الاوروبي منذ ايام يحاول ان يشكل ضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل منع اتمار بنك
فير بان يحضر هذا الح ان يكون ممثلا رسميا
عن الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لم ترضخ لهذه الضغوط لسيما
وان بنيامين نتنياهو يواجه مشكله مع شريكه
بنكير في الحكومه الذي امتنع عن التصويت
الى جانبي الحكومه في الايام الماضيه
وبالتالي كان لابد من ان يبقي تمثيل على
ما هو وبالتالي كان الموقف قويا من جانب
الاتحاد الاوروبي بالغاء الحفل برمته حيث
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي فكر في بادئ الامر
بان يخفض مستوى التمثيل في هذا الحفل
بمعنى ان لا يشارك سفراء الاتحاد الاوروبي
المعتمدين لدى اسرائيل وبالتالي لا ياتي
بنجفير من منطلق نفسه الى هذا الاحتفال او
الغاء الكلمات كلمات الترحيب للدبلوماسيين
المشاركين في هذا الاحتفال لكن القرار كان
الى الذهاب الى الموقف الاقوى وهو ان يكون
الثمن الغاء هذا الحفل بدلا من ان يشارك
فيه بن جير كما قال الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
لا يتماشى مع قيم الاتحاد بشكل عام من
ناحيه اخرى
الزعيم المعارضه يئير لبيد قال بان حكومته
السابقه عملت في الشهور الاخيره من اجل
تحسين العلاقات ما بين اسرائيل والاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن هذه الحكومه الحاليه برئاسه
تسيء الى كل ما جرى التقدم بشان هذه
الخطوات وان ما فعلته الحكومه هو عمليا
يسبب ازمه دبلوماسيه واضحه المعالم ما بين
اسرائيل والاتحاد الاوروبي من ناحيته تمر
بنجفير قال بان الاتحاد الاوروبي عمليا
يسعى او يستخدم اسلوب تكميم الافوا في
تعامله مع بن فير وان الاتحاد عليه ان
يصغي ايضا الى انتقادات الاصدقاء كما قال
في سياق رده على هذا القرار
شكرا لك الياس كرام كنت معنا من القدس